Ross McCullum has been jailed for life
with a minimum term of 23 years for the
murder of Megan nubra Megan's body was
found on a Country Lane in
leicestershire in August of 2021. her
father told the court that his family
had been ripped apart by one evil human
being Megan's brother John spoke outside
Court after the sentencing
it's difficult for me to put into words
how it felt when it became apparent Meg
was missing we found her phone or when
we were told her body had been recovered
it's a feeling I wouldn't wish upon
anyone
it's not a day that goes by where we
aren't expecting her to walk back
through the front door
we're a very close family of which Megan
was the glue that held us together our
lives have been torn apart through this
loss
I know how difficult it's been for my
parents and sister to sit at court every
day listening to the Web of Lies spun by
someone Megan not only knew but whom she
trusted someone who clearly had no love
for her at all
we're the ones now serving a life
sentence no amount of time in prison can
bring Megan back we have to carry on
with our lives as best as we can but
Megan will never leave our thoughts Meg
was an exceptional person through and
through she was and is loved by all who
knew her and was nothing but Pleasant to
those she came into contact with she had
a whole life ahead of her she was about
to buy her first home and was excited
for everything she had coming up
she was so eager to start the rest of
her life she ended up losing the one she
was living